we are a couple weeks away from our big
tour and we have another special prize
to announce with sublimation the lead
tour 2019 is closing in it's closing in
it's happening very soon and we are
excited to come and meet you we've got a
new prize tonality Medina doesn't know
what it is it is a coaching Diamond
coaching session it's a month of
mentorship from David Meltzer if you
guys don't know David Meltzer you need
to check him out he's a successful
entrepreneur he's been on entrepreneurs
the pitch or his whatever the elevator
pitch show is that they have there he's
a philanthropist he's a super successful
entrepreneur he's got a new YouTube
channel he's picking up his Instagram
game he is one of definitely one of the
good guys he is on his way up at least
on the social media world he's already
hit at big as an entrepreneur and he's
one of the one of the top three guys
that I look at and I love consuming this
stuff his approach is amazing and he's
one of the good guys and you will learn
a lot if you don't know Dave Meltzer go
look him up because you're gonna learn a
lot from him and be happy to be diving
into his world now I asked Dave for the
same deal that I got with the others so
part of our grand prize is for the tour
is the coaching session was ben cardin
coaching session with tom bill you
coaching session with Dan Locke that we
announced last week and now I asked him
hey could you give a coaching session
like all the others and he said you know
what I want to support you what you're
doing I'm gonna give a month of coaching
to whoever wins the grand prize yeah
super generous and you want to count the
time that you're spending with this guy
make sure you bring it your best
questions and I'm super pumped to
announce that prize for a tour so we've
got the three classes of prizes there's
surprises for every every ticket which
is the flex six calendar and a coaching
session of Coach Lillie $100 value
everybody gets that regardless there's
the one pour per city which is we're
gonna do a coffee shop meet up two days
after the event for two hours a couple
city will be right after next day one or
two days after right away
meeting with me and Nina and three
people you went to people potentially
one's gonna be random draw whoever's in
a city and two people whoever came the
farthest the people who put their goals
ahead of their convenience
don't break the laptop stop saying I'm
not coming to your city put your goals
ahead of your convenience come on out I
want to reward the people who come from
out of state out of the country that's
gonna make me so happy the two people
who came the furthest in that city I'm
going to meet for coffee for two hours
so there's gonna be three of you and the
two of us for two hours and I think it's
gonna be in a busy time
I'm super pumped with that and then the
Grand Prizes which is one for tour so
for the whole thing
it's six months of coaching with me one
ticket to my workshop in a by how to
make money so partly for three days
intensive the Danelaw coaching grant
cardone coaching tumble coaching and now
one month of coaching with the David
Meltzer Joe get you tickets get some
prizes looking for exceeding your tour
Nina what's our update how we doing
what's what's the latest on the tour we
got really where this coming up it's
happening soon venues for the event I
think the last one I was on was naked up
to Baker's all the cities are it's
either downtown or yeah and you know
been booking some meetings for you
thanks do podcast the one people that
they want you right you wanted me or do
we talk things so we just came out from
New York we did a stress test I was in
New York doing some some videos and
podcasts and stuff and we did a fan
meetup where if any New Yorker bought a
ticket to one of the destinations
because we're not hitting New York yeah
then I wanted to meet them for coffee
and we had it we had a nice to meet up
there but on the way back on the drive
back home we thought I want a reward
people if somebody comes to multiple
events yeah if anybody's coming to
multiple events whoever comes to the
most events we need to reward somehow
let me know in the comments what you
think if somebody's coming out to
multiple but look if somebody comes to
fire but whoever comes to the most in
the different cities I want to reward I
love I love the houses so much I want to
reward the ISOs so much so those people
come in to multiple events let me know
what kind of prize we should give away I
love your thoughts put in comments below
oh yeah we launched something new
there's something new that you could
talk about no you talk about it so I see
you're great it's like you whenever Nina
talks is like emojis don't like no so
basically is so we come up with a new
new deal if people River by 10 tickets
minimum 10 tickets or more for that
event you can even you could give it to
your friend your your family members or
even your girlfriend your boyfriend
whoever all eight of your girlfriends
don't happen sit together
you've been trouble so so if you buy 10
tickets more you can but you can get
these tickets to whoever you want and
you can make a deal with Evan what the
do is could be I want to have 101
one-hour meeting with Evan or 101 so you
say you pitched me I'm doing I'm doing a
trade yeah if you buy 10 tickets in the
city and then he's before you buy a
pitch in the email Nena 200 Evan
Carmichael calm will flash it somewhere
here pitch Nina she's gonna pitch me on
what your deal is what your offer is
that's a bonus on top of just getting
the 10 tickets he can get to your
friends and I will see if I can do that
deal or not some cities I have more time
than others so yeah we may be able to do
it or not we were giving up so like some
examples was come on my podcast to do it
do a one-hour podcast on my for my for
my channel somebody wanted me to review
the business plans you gonna sit down
with him review his business plan yeah
and so it depends on the city I have
more time
in some cities and others what if you
pitched to ice them to me and then I can
see what they're or ever could decide
that whether that deal it's if we have
time
it's a yay or a nay and then we won't
let you know you're right so you have my
10 tickets in this in minimum 10 tickets
right so so get on that I'm excited to
make some good let's make a deal this my
way if you buy three of the three
tickets and by one single ticket
there you go about 10 tickets yes what
does it end up costing three times three
it's 97 97 I like 350 just under 350 for
$350 you pitch me a deal
what bonus gonna eat that stuff she's
pretty cheap yeah chewy okay we increase
it really three it is what we committed
for 10 tickets 350 bucks you get the
pitch me you are what I want bonus on
top of the 10 tickets do you want I
still can say no though right well we
can't don't go crazy okay I want to come
live with you for a month
no don't make it to me Nina more
rejected from the guests but yes I want
to see some creative pitches see what
you guys got
okay let's get to something any other
and the other things no comments to see
what comes from last video if you have
comments questions leave them below we
will answer them in next week's video
here we go my Sarah hello our mason UK
who watch your news for a while I
noticed recently you have been announced
and get prize giveaways but they're all
for us audience I'm in need of a little
guidance coach you might think can you
help me come to the u.s. this is not
just for us audience I want if you come
from the UK to pretty much any city
you're gonna get a chance to win then
you're pretty much gonna get that well
sure you can you've got a chance for all
of the the bonus prizes like the crazy
prizes but but you're likely gonna get
the two hours bonus with me afterwards
with two other people right like this
stop thinking is for a u.s. audience
right this is how do you stand out as
someone from the UK this is it be
willing to do what the people
in your city and your country are not
that's how you get ahead and win I'm so
pumped if somebody comes in UK I'm sure
somebody well people will and they're
gonna get the opportunity they're gonna
get the growth they're gonna get the
bonuses that others aren't and they're
gonna grow insanely in 2019 Sarah HJ oh
gosh hope I can be there come don't
don't hope is not a strategy
Hatchin action let's go you wanna meet
Nina how are you Anna
Sika Sika I've heard a lot about that
law he's done at the king of high-ticket
sales he's also really speaker I would
love to be a part of his time thanks
everyone more time love you good luck
you know the grand prizes are given to
one person for the whole tour so you
might get it
and if you come into multiple cities or
you're behind the ten pop it kitchen me
get great a chance coming out but I'm
super grateful for all for Dane grins
Tom and now Dave and we've got a couple
more prizes coming up that we'll talk
about next week Carol Darley Dan Locke
yes oh wait you're coming to Albuquerque
what Nina now who knows how to pronounce
albuquerque albuquerque I haven't seen
you buy the ticket to wring over Turkey
yeah I've seen Kay are you calling
Kerala yeah you're gonna call that we
want to see you in Albuquerque the Carol
Nina Evan mashup let's make it happen to
Albuquerque
Alicia looking forward to seeing your
Sacramento watching babies every day
thank you for your team and all you do
you change people's lives the positive
appreciate your time
alicia has a leash up by her ticket to
Sacramento you know as certain as Carol
in Albuquerque is more about Alicia
alright Alicia's off the hook maybe but
we want to see you there
Sacramento foxy coming to Orlando no but
you are coming to one of the other
destinations goals ahead of your
convenience Cynthia awesome prizes love
the puppies puppies are pretty steep
yeah they're gone they're they're chill
if they're on the lap they're relaxed
and if they're on the floor they want to
get up so we have to get them on the lap
before we film so those are tossed chaos
and I go over my tripod and ruin the
film Teemo is a sheep ooh
Sanna is a miniature doesn't Eric freaky
$45.00 sounds like a bargain see you in
Denver
see you in Denver Eric 45 bucks for the
three hours it is a bargain but it's
it's it's not meant to be insanely
expensive yes Eric looking forward to
seeing you in Denver man JP JP what
awesome prizes will there be another
tour coming through Seattle in the
future no there will be no tour ever
likely coming to see I don't ever so
yeah come on out there's somebody coming
from Oregon I already know coming down
it's just too too geographically there's
nothing out there besides Seattle
Portland and Vancouver so it's too small
an area to to get a tour going so come
on down to us we'll see you in
Sacramento Jeffery neatly action
pressure makes diamonds yes that's what
we are doing we're returning people into
diamonds on this tour pursuing progress
I love the interaction between you two
we've been interaction what do you think
about that
you like that oh wow no comment on the
interaction you can in love all right
all right
xeno I like that you're figuring things
out during the announcements we're
figuring things out as we go super
pumped hello Chihuahua I like seeing the
dogs most of all I love to see how many
ninis together smiling thank you for
being awesome I love it Christopher I
can't wait except to see you in Los
Angeles
see you there Christopher looking
forward to it Andrew I really hope I can
make it to one of these thanks for tour
in the u.s. Evan you get work this
challenge really helped me and you hope
not strategy did you ticket let's see
you there I'm pumped to meet you mijo
Bell silently Steel's team on Tristana
Saturn you know that will that will not
happen
Nina is is the silent killer she is
ninja she will she will find you she
will not allow it to happen she looks
friendly and she is unless you touch her
dogs and then she becomes a raging
monster okay a raging monsters okay
pursuing progress the puppy the people
love the puppies team would you say are
awesome they are not coming on the tour
though either gonna stay when my sister
is actually gonna stay at our place she
has a dog too and the three of them are
gonna are gonna chill together so that's
like me the hardest thing for Nina is
leaving the dogs for 90 days what are
you gonna do Nina you're gonna pet me
Wow am I gonna cuddle in your lap like
that now don't you roll into a little
ball no you too
Oh as you say fur but cats though I mean
did we don't cats feel really good but
they get really smelly I could get
really smelly on your lap no okay good
Magali Laura Lally oMG I'm obsessed with
dead log all thanks to you lol I hope
you come to Texas soon not happening in
2019 come - what's this Moses one
Albuquerque Tulsa Tulsa Phoenix one a
little stream we'll see one of those
three cities let's go yeah let's make it
happen guys make it happen
this this this night has to matter it's
gonna matter bTW guys are too cute love
how raw this video is he we're keep
doing really are you gonna trash Nina
ate a lot of beet in New York and she
got her act yeah I had to even just
stretch your ass we're too cute and she
lost our otters do you think with that
yeah
listen I'm bringing the tunas factory
these videos I think the dogs are
bringing the big students okay that's it
for this week guys we will see you on
the tour click the link there right next
you go get your ticket we will see you
in your city or your traveling somewhere
else click it get your ticket we'll see
you there believe